hello america
and the united states of texas
[Applause]
it's great to be here
it's great to be here yesterday we left
new york city what a relief
leaving there for here it's like waking
up from a bad dream
it's like going from the texans to the
cowboys
you know what i don't even know what
that means
i don't know anything about sports
it's like going from joy behar's bed to
anything that isn't joy behar's bed
i'd even
i'd even take a bed of nails
that i know
and thank you by the way uh for the gift
basket i've only been in texas for one
day and i already got an ar-15
[Applause]
yeah
applauding an ar-15 i got an ar-15 a
bible and
balls in a pickle jar
that's an applause line
i
i i'm kidding we all know beto has no
balls
even caitlyn jenner would tell him to
grow a pair
i don't even get that joke
remember when he said he was coming for
your guns
and you said yeah try it nancy
this guy couldn't get a glue gun from an
art teacher
and yet he wants to run for governor
that's a joke his odds of becoming
governor are as good as hunter biden
passing a drug test
originally i had cat's name in there but
i realized uh hunter's funnier
but like beto right now the democrats
are running into a problem
whether they want to admit it or not
america is more like texas than it is
like california or new york
that means
[Applause]
this monologue is going to take the
whole show
that means americans want an america
that is more like america
and like our show a lot of people are
coming here for that very same reason
especially from california which makes
sense the u-hauls are headed in one
direction and the apocalypse in the
other
the state california is home to the
largest share of the country's
billionaires and also the highest
poverty rate they build walls around
their mansions but turn your backyards
into truck stop bathrooms except with
more poop
which means as california goes to hell
in a hand basket woven by progressives
the rich and powerful don't care so
everyone in between has no choice but to
leave for greener pastures i can't blame
them everything in texas is bigger and
better even cat has grown since she's
been here
[Music]
yeah
she's at least i think she's at least
five three
but texas had a better covered response
than new york did
probably because your governor didn't
kill more grannies than a badly placed
slip rug
if only those grandmas had been hotter
cuomo might have kept them around
that is
disgusting that is disgusting so here's
a comparison texas has no state income
tax or inherited tax but california and
new york have some of the highest in the
nation which means you texans could have
more money to spend on your kids and by
kids i mean firearms
in texas
in texas the best college football team
is named after a majestic impressive
breed of cattle
in california the best college football
team is named after condoms
[Music]
in texas
in texas you have the bustling new tesla
factory in the home base of elon musk
in california they have 39 empty
cheesecake factories and a homeless guy
living in front of each one
so one state is building cars and the
other makes people live in them
in texas you have to build a wall to
protect the border in new york we had to
build a wall to protect women from our
governor
in texas the state bird is the northern
mockingbird in new york it's a greasy
pigeon with one eye and a human finger
in his mouth
we call that the ducey
in texas you have joe rogan
in new york they have cnn
or what's left of cnn
every day someone gets fired or arrested
they're so low on employees check out
their new office assistance
[Applause]
they are
they're so desperate at cnn some
employees have been forced to harass
themselves
new york as hillary clinton
texas does not have hillary clinton
texas has rodeos
new york new york has this
there you go
that's what you call a new york rodeo
a rat with a slice of pizza
they both go well together with a
chianti in texas
in texas you have real cowboys who speak
politely and know how to handle their
guns
in california
in california they have alec baldwin
[Music]
in texas a hoedown is a dance
in
why bother
why bob all right
in new york city it's what a cop says
over his radio when a hooker is passed
out on your porch
yeah
and the two-step
the two-step is when you have to jump
over a pile of street feces
texas is known for its beautiful cattle
that's kind of true in new york city
yeah talk about uh talking about hoof
and mouth disease so here in texas
there's a vast gulf between the
residents in mexico
in california there's a vast gulf
between the governor's ears
here in texas you have the best barbecue
in the world
in california
california they put pineapples on pizza
that's like putting a mustache on
miranda lambert
which kind
she could pull it off
in california they have decaf skinny soy
no foam latte
in texas you have coffee
and testosterone
in california you have san francisco
and texas you don't
in texas
there are males and females in
california and nyc there's just one new
gender and it's called loser
they use more hair dye than they do
shampoo
in california new york you can smash and
grab in texas you smash and grab you
drop and die
kelly
[Music]
in california the homeless can poop on
your front lawn
try that in dallas and it's the last
poop you'll ever take
[Music]
in texas you produce heroes like sam
houston and davey crockett
yeah
but you know california produced this
guy
yeah i was handsome true california has
warner brothers universal studios and
paramount pictures
but texas has the great gutfeld show
so
the difference is stark it's a reminder
of who makes the country work and how
those people make it possible for the
other idiots to thrive you're the people
who create a civil lawful society a
place where the idiots who make fun of
you can live
right now you see how the press treats
the truckers that's how they think of
you the truckers are a proxy for the
typical non-journalist non-media
hard-working person it's you your family
your state so this week we salute you
texas and the hard-working fun-loving
ass kicking texans that you are let's do
this america
[Applause]
wilson
you don't mess with texas and liberals
don't mess with her
host of outnumbered and former white
house press secretary kaley mcinerney
he shops only at the finest morgues host
of fox across america
jimmy failure
she thought a 10 gallon hat was for
holding her vodka boxes contributor cats
him
[Applause]
and finally he's so big he blocks the
stars at night my massive sidekick and
the nwa world television
[Applause]
i realized uh uh jimmy i can still smell
the dead hobo you stole those boots from
you're you're a new york city cab driver
so you were exposed literally
to all sorts of people
aren't are the people better in texas or
am i just going for cheap applause no
you're absolutely not two quick things i
can't even insult your outfit i think
you did a good job of shopping at your
favorite store forever five foot one
yes fair enough but texas is the america
a lot of us grew up in they have freedom
and buckies everybody knows bucky
there you go
bucky
for real bucky's is the only store in
the world where you can get a club
sandwich an air freshener for your car
and a grenade launcher
but this is why when you hear things
about beto for instance yeah they say
like oh abbott's beating beto by seven
points in the polls it's actually closer
if you count the points on beto's
license um narrows it down a little bit
that was good that was that was it was
that you and me think about it that was
a unb it took a minute um but the god's
honest truth is there's a guy who talks
on the radio here in texas on ktbb and
tyler and i'm sorry
alice thank you okay i will tell you
that texas is never turning blue after
what biden did the border that's just
how it works right okay
selling seriously selling texans a
democrat after biden is like selling
carnival cruises after titanic it's kind
of challenging
kaylee always great to see you uh
what are your thoughts about being
excited jeff lands
[Applause]
thank you as you know greg i'm a
floridian and i feel like you guys are
my brethren here in texas
i mean
really seriously i can't figure it out
we played the license plate game in
florida where literally like i sit and
drive in my car i'm like there we go
there's michigan and new york in new
jersey and it's really fun i'm sure you
do that here and i can't figure it out
greg our californians fleeing to texas
faster than the abused staffers are
fleeing kamala's office i just don't
know but i think the answer is yes yes
yes in uh and
in florida and texas you count license
plates in new york city you make them
see what i did there cat that was really
clever off the cuff stuff you can learn
a lot from me
you know i'll tell you right now you
know that the ceo the president of fox
is in this in this audience he won't say
where what can you tell them to convince
them to pick up fox and leave and come
here
well first of all i want to thank you
about making that comment about me being
a booze bag in front of the president
and ceo
usually i have to spend all this time
worrying about whether she heard those
things or not but now that i just know
you've saved me so much time
so i appreciate that um there's a lot of
things there's you know the freedom
uh but also the big thing is that here
people do not hate us yes which is nice
thank you
i love you too see it's so nice people
like smile at you
not in that like deranged perverted way
where they're laying on the street with
their pants down surrounded by bags of
drugs new york we got a lot of that yes
but just like normal people that are
happy to see us yes
so
tyrus the interesting thing about texas
this is the only place where you
actually look smaller
[Music]
look gut fell just because texas is the
only place where a size 17 boot can be
bought off the shelf there's no reason
for you to get an attitude okay
and correction the state bird out here
is grown ass man this is just still this
is still man country yes where you can
open doors and get in a fight in a bar
and still be friends by the time you go
to church on sunday it's all good
[Applause]
so did you have a question
what are you planning to do this week
besides the show tyrus well my week well
first of all i'm excited to spend my
birthday in texas today thank you so
much
not going to bring up that you forgot
thank you kat for your warm message i
really appreciate it got phil only
working with you almost a decade but
nothing you know i guess it was just
over your head
a lot of things are i don't even
remember my birthday let's be honest
right right yeah because you don't have
a birthday of a birth week yes
you send out invitations a month ahead
of time yes but no texas is a great
place and the one thing i would like to
say to the california because i was i
grew up there before i got the sense to
get out
you're welcome yes but leave that
progressive crap over there exactly
all right
we gotta go
up next can the democrats stay alive by
running on hatred of 40. hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else